you get a lot done on the internet that
means you probably have a lot of
accounts with tons of websites right but
do you use the same password on all of
them or do you almost use the same
password and change it a little bit for
each site well that's a problem if you
use the same password on every website
and just one of these websites gets
broken into by cyber criminals and
there's always one site you use that's
not secure then those thieves can get
ahold of the passwords of everyone on
that site and then they can use them to
break in to all those other accounts
these kinds of break-ins happen far more
often than you think sometimes they even
happen without the hacked website
knowing so don't reuse your passwords
but wait if you have lots of website
accounts and each of them now needs a
unique password how can you possibly
remember them all
aren't we supposed to keep our passwords
in our heads and never write them down
writing them down isn't actually that
bad at all yes if you use lots of
passwords write them down and keep them
somewhere safe like your wallet
then you'll at least know if your
written passwords go missing or get
stolen that's more than you might know
if you use just one house word
everywhere and then a website you use it
silently hacker an even safer plan
though is to use a password manager
password managers are programs you can
download for your phone or computer they
will create store and even automatically
fill in unique passwords on
sites and other online services they can
keep all your account details safe and
synchronize them between all your
devices so you never have to remember
all those passwords again you can search
for password manager reviews to find out
what the most secure net users out there
prefer use password managers to resist
the temptation to use one password on
all your sites remember it's a trap
there is one catch with all password
managers though password managers do you
need a password for themselves one that
you type into the manager to unlock all
the others you'll want that password to
be extra secure but easy to remember
because it's the one password you won't
be able to store in your password
manager but that one password will keep
you a lot safer in a sometimes dangerous
net to find out how to create a strong
but memorable password for password
managers and more check out our guide on
strong passwords or visit surveillance
self defense from the Electronic
Frontier Foundation